[MUSIC - PEARL JAM, "PENDULUM"]
MALE SPEAKER: I'll talk.
MALE SPEAKER: Who
the hell are you?
MALE SPEAKER: The United
States of America.
FEMALE SPEAKER: You're
building a weapon.
MALE SPEAKER: It's called
an atomic chain reaction.
MALE SPEAKER: There is a spy.
MALE SPEAKER: You are
in a world of trouble
from sea to shining sea.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'll bet you
overhear all kinds of secrets.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to "Talks at Google."
Today it's my pleasure to
welcome David Ellison, Dana
Goldberg, Sam Shaw,
and Marcy Ross
from "Manhattan" and
Skydance Productions.
Thank you guys for
joining us today.
So I would love to
know-- this is to Sam.
What made you go, I
want to make a show
about making the atomic bomb.
SAM SHAW: First off,
thanks for having us.
It's great to be here,
but that's actually not
what I set out to do.
This is a creative
process that I would not
recommend to anyone, but
about six or seven years ago I
sat down to write something
about a totally different war
in a different decade.
I was writing what I thought
was going to be-- and also
by the way, not a TV show.
So basically I struck out
in every possible way.
I thought I was going to
write a feature about the war
on terror set in the
present, and about people
who are involved in matters
of national security
and secret work, and what
the implications are for them
in their personal lives.
And in the process
of doing what I
was training to do as
a journalist, which
is what I did before I wrote
for television, which is that I
just buried myself in research.
What I began to
discover is, if you're
sort of interested in
questions of national security
and this sort of
towering secrecy edifice
that is at the heart of so much
of our political conversation
these days, you find
that all roads lead back
to the New Mexico
desert and that really
the story of the
birth of the bomb
is kind of the story of
the birth of 21st century
America and the world
that we're living in now.
So I went down a very,
very, very deep rabbit hole,
and I'm still down
there somewhere now six
or seven years later.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Hidden
away in the desert.
SAM SHAW: I am.
I am [INAUDIBLE].
DANA HAN-KLEIN: So
at what point did
this come to Skydance, though?
At what point do you
go, OK, you know what?
It is going to be
television show.
It's going to be set in
this time in this era.
Who's going to help me make it?
SAM SHAW: So I wrote a draft.
I revised it.
I wrote about 20
drafts, and finally it
became the thing it was
sort of going to be,
and I partnered up with my
partner in crime creatively,
Tommy Schlamme, our executive
producer and director,
who is very well
known in television.
Won about a million Emmys
for "The West Wing"--
principally is what
he's known for.
And then we went looking for
some congenial partners who
would help us get this thing
made, and first of all,
it's an incredibly ambitious
and complicated show to make.
Period.
Full stop, but particularly
on television, particularly
on basic cable.
So finding people who had the
right creative sensibilities,
who loved this subject
matter and loved the story as
much as we did-- it
was sort of a miracle
that we wound up with
the folks on this stage.
And so we sat down
together, I guess, probably
about-- I don't know--
two and a half years ago
or something like that.
It was this very refreshing
thing where it was really
just a few people in the room,
and we talked passionately
about the subject matter, and
by the end of the meeting,
they said, let's go make
a TV show, and we did.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Was there
anything scary to you
guys about the scope of
this television show?
It's a period piece.
It's about a very tough
time in US history.
DAVID ELLISON: Dana, please.
DANA GOLDBERG: Not really.
To be honest, a credit to
Sam and, as you said, Tommy.
We read the script,
and we just loved it.
We thought it was
beautiful, and as you said,
we all got in a room
together, and we
felt like we really found people
who so understood the subject
matter, and the
beauty of the script
and for us the
beauty of the show
is, yes, you have this
incredible historical backdrop,
but it was really about the
characters, and to this day
we always say one of the
first things that Sam said to
us is, yes, it's a
show about Los Alamos,
and yes it's about people
who built the bomb.
It's really a show
about secrets and lies,
and it's about the
secrets and lies
that, yes, the government
can tell scientists,
but it's really about the lies
between husbands, and wives,
and families, and what the
ramifications of those lies
are.
So we felt incredibly
comfortable in that room.
MARCY ROSS: And I
just want to add
it's also about timing,
because the landscape has
changed so much in the
television business.
So it was a perfect timing
between incredible material,
broad, hugely ambitious
subject matter, and scope,
but the television
business was able-- there
was a network there that
was able to support it
and was not afraid of it.
And I think a few years ago
people would've definitely
been afraid of it.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: I think you
make an excellent point,
and one of the things that
I loved about the show,
and I think that we here at
Google especially can relate to
is it's this kind
of isolation where
you're working on something
that you can't talk about.
And you're maybe surrounded by
a bunch of other really smart
people, but those are the only
ones you can talk to you about,
and there's competition,
and there's personalities,
and there's all sorts
of that, but they're
working with a very
technical subject matter.
How do you make that
relatable for audiences?
Is that where the
character part comes in?
SAM SHAW: Well, it
is actually in a way.
The job that I had immediately
before I got the chance
to make this show
that I'd been hoping
to make for all these
years was working
on a Showtime show,
"Masters of Sex,"
which is also a show
oddly-- they share some DNA.
It's also a show about
science, and it's
about the collision
between science,
and culture, and ethics, but
we had this rule of thumb
on that show, which is that sex
could never exist on "Masters
of Sex" just for sex's sake.
Although by the
way, sex is probably
more obvious as a sales
pitch to a network
than nuclear physics
is, but the deal
was it always had to be
a vehicle for character
storytelling.
So to the extent that a sex
scene could sort of help
us to come to understand what
made these characters tick
or sort of dramatize some
essential conflict-- then
it belonged on the show.
It wasn't there to titillate.
Now, I don't know
how many people are
titillated by nuclear physics.
I happen to find it really,
really, really fascinating,
I must say, as a non-physicist.
I'm not a scientist,
but I've come
to be really fascinated
by the science,
but for us it was the same rule.
There is a lot of
science in our show,
but our challenge-- and it's
sort of the gift of the subject
matter-- is to find
ways to let science
be an engine for deep
character storytelling,
to let it reveal things
about our characters
that we didn't know, and
we're constantly trying
to find new ways to do that.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: You
mentioned the science of it.
Did you guys bring in
consultants for it?
I assume you did a bunch of
historical research on this.
SAM SHAW: We just
made it all up.
[LAUGHTER]
No, we didn't.
We have a few-- I was
going to say an army.
It's as small army.
We have a few incredibly smart
and really, really heroically
patient consultants
who work with us.
Now, all the writers on our
show-- we love the research,
and we love the subject
matter, but we get stuff wrong,
and it's an incredibly
specific set of talents
you have to have as a
consultant to understand
what the story needs are that
at the heart of the question.
And so we have a physicist at
UCLA named David Saltzburg, who
is incredible, and there's
a nuclear historian
named Alex Wellerstein,
who writes exclusively
about issues of secrecy
and the atomic bomb,
and does it really brilliantly.
So he helps keep us honest, too.
MARCY ROSS: It's really
fun when John always
talks about having to
familiarize himself
with the math and the science,
and he was a complete math nerd
in high school, and how this has
made him feel so much smarter.
SAM SHAW: Yeah, the thing
that John Benjamin Hickey, who
plays Frank on our
show, likes to say
is that before he
started the show
he called up some buddies who
work on "Big Bang Theory,"
and he was like, you've
got to give me some tips.
And they said, always make
sure that they give you
the last couple numbers of
the equation, that they just
tell you what those are.
And they say, action, and
you just write them in,
and you look very, very smart.
He does it very well.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: He does.
How do you strike a balance
between incorporating
the obviously real world events
and characters-- like you
can't have a show
about the atomic bomb
without Oppenheimer.
How do you strike a balance
between that and then exploring
this universe that you
guys have also created,
because it's a
fictionalization of the history
that we're familiar with.
SAM SHAW: Yeah, well
there's two things.
One is-- that I was sort of
amazed by-- actually for such
an incredibly important
moment in our history--
I think it is an origin
story, and it really
has a lot to say
about who we became.
For such an important
moment, actually I
think a lay audience doesn't
really know a lot about it,
and that was the first thing
that was exciting to me
about the story-- is that I
knew a bit about the science,
but I did not know that
there is this town that
was built almost overnight
in the desert on top
of a dead volcano, surrounded
by barbed wire fences.
And all these incredibly
brilliant people, the greatest
geniuses on the planet, came
together to build this weapon,
but we were just talking
about this this morning.
They brought their families,
and there were kids,
when there are kids,
you need schools,
and you need teachers to
teach those kids at schools.
And you need grocers,
and you need contractors
to build the buildings.
So there's this huge, teaming
community that cropped up
overnight, and only the tiniest
minority, a tiny percentage,
less than 10% of
the people living
in this place had any idea what
the purpose of the town was.
So that was this incredibly
riveting thing to me,
but that was what
really captured
me-- was that emotional
dynamic, what it is to try
to lead a life in this place.
And what it suggested was that
we needed to tell story really
about fictional characters
set against the backdrop
of this historical moment so
that we would have the freedom
to kind of explore their
interior lives in the way
that we wanted to.
Now of course, Oppenheimer
pops up from time
to time, mostly in
the first season
as this kind of Olympian god.
His shadow is cast
over the events.
He plays more of a role
in the second season,
but for the most part,
what we tried to do
is use the history
as kind of a stage
on which the dramas of
these fictional characters
are played out.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: And the stage of
the town-- my understanding is
it's a big set.
Could you guys talk
about the commitment to--
DAVID ELLISON: [INAUDIBLE], Sam.
MARCY ROSS: You want to go?
SAM SHAW: Well,
here's what I'll say.
MARCY ROSS: It's an
extraordinary experience.
It's sort of like being
on a Google campus,
where it's all encompassing.
When you visit the set--
and basically Sam and Tommy
created this environment
that, if it's raining,
our actors will be wet, just
as they were wet and muddy
as they were tromping through
the town back in the '40s.
So there's a level of
immersion and reality
that's kind of extraordinary.
When you visit it
it, the ashtrays
have the exact brand
stubs of cigarettes.
You open up the drawers.
Everything is accurate
at such a deep level.
It's sort of extraordinary.
SAM SHAW: No, it's nuts.
And it's so antithetical to the
way that TV usually gets made.
Usually just because
of the budgets
and these incredibly
punishing schedules,
we have to make these
episodes so quickly.
So usually you're
on a sound stage,
and you're shooting on
stages, and the lighting
is really controlled, but
Tommy had the audacity
to think that the way to make
this show feel the way that we
wanted it to feel, all of us,
was just do what the Army did,
which is that we built a town.
And we are lucky enough
to find this 11 acre
compound of 1940s buildings in
Santa Fe that we got use of,
and we rehabbed it.
And so it really is like
Colonial Williamsburg,
except instead of
churning butter
you go and you invent
the apocalypse.
DANA HAN-KLEIN:
There's something
that I found interesting that
I feel like there's actually
more diversity in the
show than there would
have been in the actual town.
And the internet sometimes
[? might lie to me ?] also.
Maybe back that up, but I
like seeing the diversity,
and I like seeing this
representation of also
these characters who were very
marginalized in the history
books, where it's
like, yeah, there
are people of all
shapes, colors,
whatever contributing
to these projects,
and yet we don't
get to see them.
Was that something you
knew from the beginning
that you wanted to incorporate
so you could explore
those issues, or was that
something that came along
as you were developing it?
SAM SHAW: Well, quite
honestly it was a challenge.
That is a really
tricky question when
you're dealing with
the historical time,
because-- well look, we're
interested in the fact
that antisemitism is part of
the conversation of our show.
Look at what was
happening in Europe,
and that was the pretext for
this race to build a bomb,
and so it was important
for that to be
part of a conversation
in spite of the fact
that a lot of the
physicists in this place
were expatriate
European Jews, but we
were somewhat constrained
because it was largely
a pretty white community
of scientists there,
but that wasn't
entirely the case.
So we have tried to find ways to
bring in as diverse an ensemble
of voices as we can in
the show, and that's
part of what's exciting to us.
And in writing about women at
Los Alamos, and the experience
of female physicists, and the
experience of brilliant women
who were wives, who were
excluded from the secret--
those are the kind of
people who I think usually
are left on the margins of
stories about the Manhattan
Project and about this
moment in history.
And so it was
interesting to us to try
to find a way to make those
voices part of the discussion.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: And just from
a personal point of view.
My grandmother worked on
the Manhattan Project.
Not in Los Alamos.
MARCY ROSS: Wow.
SAM SHAW: That's amazing.
DANA HAN-KLEIN:
So it's very nice
to see her-- not her exact
work, but her contribution
rewarded in a way.
It's like something
that only maybe
my family would
have known about,
but now it's like, oh no, look.
There were ladies there.
There were people of color.
There were all these sorts
of different characters
contributing to history,
like America's melting pot.
So I appreciate that personally
as an audience member,
seeing this kind
of representation.
And you bring up a great
point about the women,
where I love that there
are these two very hyper
intelligent strong
women who were
trapped in a time era that isn't
necessarily welcoming of that.
And one of them is in a position
of being included to a degree,
being a contributing
member on the project,
and then this other character
who's just kind of trapped
and sort of being punished
for her intelligence.
So I would love to
know, is that something
that you discovered going-- as
you developed the characters,
or was it something ahead of
time you saw these situations
and went this is how I'm
going to represent the two
ends of that spectrum?
SAM SHAW: Well,
it is a spectrum,
and it evolves in
the second season.
One thing that was interesting,
but also constraining
for us in the first
season is that
a few of our
principal characters--
Liza, played by Olivia
Williams-- Abby,
played by Rachel
Brosnahan-- they
are at a structural disadvantage
in our storytelling,
because they're not
able to penetrate
to the nucleus of this secret.
And that means that they
can't put their hands
on this sort of
central drama that
is the spine around
which the show is built.
That changes in the
second season in some ways
that I don't want to
say too much about,
because I think it's
exciting storytelling,
but it activates
them as characters
in the story in a
really exciting way.
But yeah, absolutely we
were interested in writing
about that and exploring
those questions.
There is something fascinating
to me about the fact
that this moment, World War II,
actually created opportunities
for women that hadn't
existed before, some of which
went away when the war ended.
And so that was a thing
that-- and Katja Herbers
plays Helen in our show.
She talks about that,
as that, in an odd way,
although she's working to end
this incredibly catastrophic
war, she's sort of aware of
this bittersweet fact, which
is that it's like the chariot
turns back into a pumpkin
as soon as that war
ends in a way for her.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: I'd love
to talk about season two,
because I cheated.
I've seen a little bit
of it, and it definitely
feels very intense.
It feels like the
stakes have been raised.
Obviously the real life
stakes were being raised.
We're getting closer and
closer to real life events
that they needed to get
this bomb built for,
but was it a conscious
decision going into season two
to be like, OK, let's
really turn up the heat.
We've established this world.
We've established
these characters.
Or was it more based on
the timeline of where
they were in the real world?
MARCY ROSS: I'll
start [INAUDIBLE].
It's really difficult to
speak about the show sitting
next to Sam because no one talks
about the show as well as Sam
does, but from our
perspective, looking at it,
what season two really
feels like is 10 chapters
of incredibly wild thriller.
To me it's like
the span of it is
how do you-- it takes
place over 15 months--
and how do you put that
much story in 10 episodes?
It's kind of extraordinary
how they did it
so that it's like that--
it's so unexpected to have
this kind of thrill ride.
When you actually
know the ending,
but you still are biting
your nails thinking,
how are they going
to solve this?
Or what's the
outcome going to be?
SAM SHAW: Yeah, that
was our sort of goal,
in a way-- was we all felt that
by the end of the first season
the storytelling has hit
this break neck pace,
and every event has huge
ramifications for everybody
in the world of the show.
There's a sense that
the people who come out
the other end of this
experience are not
going to be exactly
the people who
went into it in the beginning.
And what we didn't want to do
was take our foot off the gas,
and slow down, and
rebuild, and have
four or five seasons of
exposition to set of stories.
And partially that just
wouldn't have felt honest given
the subject matter.
They're careening toward
this event, and it's coming.
And in a way, it just
felt important to us
to have the storytelling
accelerate as well.
So that's kind of what
this second season is.
We throw the characters through
the windshield of the story.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: I have to ask.
For those of you at
the studio, is it
one of the scary moments
when you're like,
this show has to have
an end theoretically.
It's great.
It's successful, but there
is a real world event
that ends it, or is the idea
just sort of let it organically
play out?
DAVID ELLISON: No, I
think one of things
that was really
remarkable when we first
got involved with the show
was-- as Dana said earlier,
Sam had written a script which
we all fell in love with,
but when we were fortunate
enough to partner with Sam
and actually took the
show to the network,
Sam knew what all five seasons
were before we started shooting
a frame of episode one.
And I think what is
really interesting is
the bomb dropping-- there is so
much in the history about Los
Alamos that happened even
after those events actually
occurred that there is so much
history and texture to explore.
And what Sam has
done brilliantly,
much like if you think about
something like "Titanic," which
was a huge phenomenon
and everyone
knew that the boat
sank at the end of it,
but you're riveted
by the character
stories that are taking place.
And I think really
the familial stories
that Sam has told in the show
are riveting, and beautiful,
and incredibly exciting to
watch on a weekly basis.
They keep you
wanting to come back,
despite the event that you might
be hurling yourself towards.
SAM SHAW: Yeah, I
will also say, too,
that just-- because it
would seem like a story that
has an obvious conclusion--
we sort of are brushing up
against this, but it would
seem like a story that
has an obvious endpoint, but
the truth is the trick up
the sleeve narratively
to me has always
been that, while
it appears to be
a show about the
end of World War II,
it's really a show about the
beginning of the Atomic Age
that followed it.
And so for me,
from my standpoint,
actually the most exciting
and interesting story material
takes place after
this war has ended,
and Los Alamos
remained the center
for weapons development
for decades afterward.
Still is, but that great
moral clarity of World War II
was gone, and so at that moment
where we enter this Cold War
arms race instead
and what that means
for people who have been
party to this act of violence
for good or for ill.
That's a really exciting
part of the story to us.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: I'd love to
know without any spoilers what's
the topic that you're
all most excited that we
get to explore in season two?
MARCY ROSS: For me, it's
always about the characters,
and I think there's
not one character that
ends up at the end of
season two that anyone
will have seen coming.
So I really don't want
to give anything away,
but I think, too, what
Sam did so brilliantly
is the notion of
how we reintroduce
Frank Winters at the end.
It's such a cliffhanger
what happened to him,
and it's very unconventional
how we start the season and then
the slow reveal of
who Frank is, and I
think people-- the journey
he's on this season-- he
and Charlie-- it's kind of
an extraordinary melding,
and mixing, and coming
out on the other side,
if that's not too vague.
DANA GOLDBERG: It's
a little vague.
MARCY ROSS: It's a lot vague,
because I'm staring at--
DANA HAN-KLEIN: But you're
preserving the audience.
You're not spoiling anything.
SAM SHAW: It's just building
on what Marcy was saying.
It's funny talking
about this at Google,
because one thing that's
been interesting to us
in writing the show is it is
very much a show about work,
and the culture
of work, and what
it is when you're in
an enclosed environment
with really really, really
smart people working
on the same project.
And I can analogize
in my own small way
to the experience of working
on a show in a writer's room,
but there's a
moment where you get
lost in the fog
of the work, and I
think that was very much the
experience of a lot of people
who worked on the bomb.
So the thing to me
that is most exciting
about this second season,
besides the fact that we've
talked about an atomic
bomb for a while
and we might actually
get to see one this year,
is the journey that Frank--
that John Benjamin Hickey takes
Frank on over the course
of the season, which
is from being the
person who is in a way
the most dogged, Ahab-like
proponent of the idea
that we have to build this
bomb and end this war,
and a guy who has
compartmentalized and repressed
a lot of misgivings
and self-doubt in order
to deliver that weapon.
He goes through a
set of circumstances
that fundamentally changes
his relationship to this thing
that he's helped
midwife into the world,
and I think that
generates some really,
really exciting and powerful
character storytelling.
And John, I have to say, is just
completely extraordinary in it
this season, as all of
our cast members are.
MARCY ROSS: Yeah,
what Sam just said.
DANA GOLDBERG: I'll
say for me again,
going back to the very
first thing Sam ever
said about this project
is it's the ramifications
of those secrets and those lies.
You specifically pointed
out the female characters
who, in season one, obviously
don't really necessarily
have the knowledge of what's
going on in Los Alamos.
And for me in season
two, it's fascinating,
because with
knowledge comes power,
but in this case also
can come a great burden
and what happens when
people who don't really
know what's going there find
out and how it affects someone
on both a very personal
level, and then
how it changes their characters,
because again suddenly you
know something you
didn't know before,
and you know the
ramifications, and everything
changes as a result. And I think
the way Sam and the writers
have written that this
season is just extraordinary.
DAVID ELLISON: Again, it's
dovetailing off of it.
It really is the
character journeys
that our ensemble goes
through this season,
and one of the relationships
that I've always loved
is the Frank and
Charlie relationship.
And obviously those
characters in season one
take incredible turns
in terms of where
the relationship
begins and where
the relationship ultimately
ends, and I think
that in season two, without
wanting to give anything away,
Sam has really dialed that
in to a whole new level.
And it's really,
really exciting,
and we can't wait
for people to see it.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Great.
MARCY ROSS: Can I just
add one more thing
that I think is so significant.
What Sam has done
is the story is
told in a less linear fashion
than it was in season one.
So you really are leaning in.
So I think that
that's just really
a fascinating device
of storytelling.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: I'm curious
to know-- because Skydance
has done all these huge,
amazing, big blockbustery ones,
and then now you guys have
these two very successful shows.
And one is this
historical grounded--
and the other one is on
Netflix, and so what prompted
you guys to go, you know what?
These are our two.
This is when we're going to TV.
DAVID ELLISON: When
we first set out
to start the television
division of the company,
we wanted to do a
show that we felt
like could be the calling
card and the identity
for the company.
So much about what you do first
defines you in entertainment.
And much akin to when we did
"True Grit" with the Coen
Brothers as our first movie,
we wanted it to be something
that, A, first and foremost,
everybody here loved,
but that we believed
could achieve
the-- if we all did our
jobs collectively right,
hopefully a level of both
commercial and critical
success, which is always such
a hard thing to find something
that really rises to
those two occasions.
And "Manhattan" was
the first script
that we read that all of us
absolutely fell in love with.
Dana actually read it
first, and called me,
and said you have to read
this, and read it immediately.
And then all of us collectively
looked at each other and said,
we have to get this made.
And got in a room with
Sam and with Tommy,
and we were fortunate
enough that they decided
to trust us to help get this
show out into the world,
and we found terrific
partners at Lion's Gate
and then at WGN,
where everybody shared
the same passion for the story.
And we're very thankful to now
be heading into season two.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Great.
DANA GOLDBERG: I'd say
one of the things for us
that's guiding us, whether
you're talking about features
and whether it's a big
budget sci-fi fantasy movie,
or you're talking
about historical drama,
it all goes back to the story.
It really is just,
do we love the story?
Do we love these
characters, and do we
love the possibilities
of where they can go?
Then combine with, is
the story in the hands?
So "Manhattan" was an
obvious yes across the board
as a result of
that, because to be
able to spend time
with these characters
in this incredible backdrop
for us was a no brainer.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Marcy, I
want to go back to a point
that you made
earlier that I love.
You talked about the changing
television landscape,
and I feel like
with all the respect
for a show that's
hyper intelligent,
and about science,
and all that stuff.
MARCY ROSS: Didn't
stand a chance.
Did not stand a chance.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Not necessarily
going to stand a chance,
but it's great
that you guys have
found a home for
it, and also, again,
"Grace and Frankie" on Netflix.
So you guys have really
embraced this divergence
of trusting your audience.
Are there other projects
that you guys are
excited to work on with that, or
are you incubating these babies
right now?
MARCY ROSS: Oh, yes.
No, I have to say this is an
amazing time for television.
I've been in the business--
in the conventional television
business, for over 20 years.
So for me to look
out at the wild west,
and there's 57 places
to sell content,
and there's so many
different ways to communicate
your specific vision for a show,
or to have a writer like Sam,
or Marta Kauffman,
or we're working
with some other
fantastic writers,
and basically sit with them
and say, what you want to do?
Don't think about where
you want to sell it.
Don't think about what
the potential of it
is in terms of business,
but just you do it,
and you do it as best and with
most integrity that you can,
and we will find a home for it.
You never used to be
able to program that way.
So it's creative drives
everything right now,
and that is
incredibly liberating.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: As
an audience member,
that's always nice to hear.
MARCY ROSS: No, it's wonderful.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: I think my
last question for you guys
would be, if you were
living on the hill,
what job would you
have liked to have?
SAM SHAW: That's a
very tricky question.
MARCY ROSS: Oh,
that's a good one.
DANA GOLDBERG: Wow.
SAM SHAW: What job would
I have liked to have?
Well, I've got to tell
you, Abby Isaac's--
DANA GOLDBERG:
Oh, you took mine.
SAM SHAW: I'm sorry,
but I've got to say.
MARCY ROSS: Oh my god.
SAM SHAW: I was going
to say the job I would
be tempted to take
would be her job, which
was the case in this place.
All phone calls and all
letters were censored,
and so all phone calls
were eavesdropped upon.
So one of our characters
actually sits in that room
and listens to
phone calls all day.
It's like those
are her radio soap
operas for the interior lives
of other people she knows,
and I also know it would be
the worst job for me possibly
to have, because I would
hear things that I just--
and also I'm absolutely,
completely, constitutionally
incapable of keeping secrets.
So I would be the last
person to have that job.
DAVID ELLISON: Marcy?
MARCY ROSS: He took the one.
DANA GOLDBERG: He
took the obvious job.
SAM SHAW: Sorry, guys.
DANA HAN-KLEIN:
There's an entire bank
full of people doing that job.
You could ask for the same one.
MARCY ROSS: I know.
SAM SHAW: We could all
work together, guys.
MARCY ROSS: Gosh, I think
I'd want to be the spy.
Is that weird?
DANA HAN-KLEIN: No.
MARCY ROSS: I want to be Meeks.
I want to be Meeks
and be the spy.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Dana,
any preference on?
DANA GOLDBERG: Well, I was
going to go with Abby's job,
because you do-- you're
the one person who,
if you want to get it, can
get all the information
and not have to do
anything with it.
I'm going to go
with-- he may not
be the nicest character
in the world necessarily,
but William Peterson plays
a character named Darrow
this season on the show,
and he's the opposite end
of the spectrum.
He's what do you do if you
have all of the information,
and you are the guy that
everybody is looking at,
and you have a very
clear point of view,
and you think you're right?
I'm not saying I would
want to necessarily be him,
but I might want
to have his job.
MARCY ROSS: You're kind
of scaring me, Dana.
DAVID ELLISON: I'd want
to be a scientist there.
I grew up computer
programming when I was 13
and took pre-med and
physics class for fun
throughout college.
And so to be on the
cutting edge of technology
is something that I would
have found fascinating.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Wonderful.
DANA GOLDBERG: Which
job would you want?
DANA HAN-KLEIN:
Oh, that's tough.
I think I'd want to be
one of the boss jobs.
SAM SHAW: There you go.
Why not?
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Or not
Oppenheimer's responsibilities,
but that job wouldn't be bad.
Well, we have a moment
for audience questions
if anyone has one.
I know there's at least one.
AUDIENCE: I'll pick
one up on the mic.
Could you describe
some of the side
elements of creating the show?
For example, the music,
the costuming-- there's
a mix between Icelandic post
rock with Jonsi and Alex,
and then just the period songs.
How do create that
balance and mixture?
SAM SHAW: Well, this
is a conversation
that it started as a
conversation between me
and Tommy Schlamme, our
director, about what
the show should feel like.
What should it look like?
What should it feel like?
This was the moment-- look,
I'd been a huge fan of His
I was a huge fan
of "The West Wing,"
but it was a moment when I
understood that we were going
to have a really great
partnership working
on "Manhattan" together,
because we both really responded
to just this-- there's
something a little unsettling,
and fundamentally strange,
and "Twilight Zone"
like about the
subject matter itself.
The Hill was this
odd, secret suburb,
and it became really
important for us
to find a way to tell a story
about this moment in the Second
World War, but not to fall into
all the conventional tropes
of World War II
storytelling, because we
know what those feel like.
There are incredible movies, and
there has been incredible TV.
"Band of Brothers" is incredible
as a World War II story,
but that's not what
this story was.
This is a true life
science fiction story.
So we were so lucky when
Jonsi and Alex came on
to compose the score for
us in the first season,
and that's like a metonymy
for the whole thing for us,
which is that these
guys who in some ways
were a crazy choice--
Jonsi is the front man
of the Icelandic
rock band Sigur Ros,
and their music is this
ambient, eerie, sometimes
electronic music.
And there was just something
really fruitful and exciting
to us about the mix between
that sound and then these great
period-- [INAUDIBLE]
you hear the radio,
and it's-- hear Carmen
Miranda on the radio,
and what's not to like?
MARCY ROSS: Also it's the
timelessness of the piece
and the subject matter.
It's not just rooted
in that one event.
SAM SHAW: Well that's
absolutely right.
This is a very
important thing to us--
is that we see this as an
incredibly contemporary story.
It starts in 1943.
We're up to 1945 by the
end of the second season,
but I think it has a
real mirror to hold up
to this contemporary
moment we're
living in right now, and so
just the aesthetic of the show--
how we shoot it, what the
visual reference points were,
what it sounds like-- it was
really important that we lift
it out of a box of feeling like
it's some sort of powdered wig
period drama, but it is a little
harder to pin down than that.
AUDIENCE: I guess
one other question.
So as you're entering the season
two, the reception for the show
has gotten bigger.
I see that there's
reviews and recaps
in "Scientific American."
What's been the reception
among history buffs,
historical enthusiasts,
or people whose relatives
worked on the Hill?
Are they clamoring for
lectures? [? How's it going? ?]
SAM SHAW: It's been
really, really gratifying.
I will say when we first started
the show out of the gates,
I think we were the
only TV show-- there's
a culture now online of doing
weekly reviews of episodes
of TV.
I'm not sure there's
another show on the air that
was getting weekly recaps
written by "Scientific
American," as you say, and--
MARCY ROSS: "Popular Mechanics."
SAM SHAW: "Popular
Mechanics," but that
seemed like a really,
really pretty cool punk rock
kind of thing to be a show
that was getting weekly reviews
by "Popular Mechanics,"
but the truth
is scientists in the
science community
has been incredibly
supportive of the show
and really welcoming.
I know there's a regular
Tuesday night pizza
party at some bar in Los
Alamos where people watch
the show and talk about it.
MARCY ROSS: Have you gone?
SAM SHAW: I have not gone.
As I say, I can't watch
the show with other people.
I'm too much of a hermit.
Can't watch people
watch the show,
but no, it's been
really gratifying.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Wonderful.
Well, thank you all so
much for joining us today.
We're looking forward
to season two.
MARCY ROSS: Thank you.
DANA GOLDBERG:
Thanks for having us.
SAM SHAW: Thank you
so much for having us.
DAVID ELLISON: Thank you.
Great to be here.
MARCY ROSS: Thank you.